في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله قتل جدد
على يد القوات الاسرائيليه اذ قالت وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه ان شابين فلسطينيين
قتل ليله الاربعاء الخميس خلال اقتحام
الجيش الاسرائيلي مخيمه جنين في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله حيث دارت مواجهات
واشتباكات عنيفه ياتي هذا غداه يوم دام
شاهدته الضفه الغربيه المحتله اصفر عن
مقتل سته فلسطينيين برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي ومنذ اثار مارس الفائز شن
الجيش الاسرائيلي نحو ثلاثه الاف عمليه
دهم وعمليه امنيه في الضفه لاسيه في منطقه
جنين ولسه معنا الان من رام الله مراسلنا
ماجد سعيد ماجد صباح الخير ما هي الاجواء
حاليا في الضفه الغربيه المحتله بعد يوم
دام امس
يعني كانت هذه الليله ايضا داميه
لقتل فلسطينيين وسبق ذلك ايضا مساء امس
قتل الفلسطينيين اخر ثلاثه فلسطينيين من
مدينه جنين من محافظه جنين 2 من مخيم جنين
والثالث من من بلده قباطيه القريبه من
المدينه اضافه الى ما ذكرت همم هناك خمسه
فلسطينيين اخرين قبل يومين او قبل يومين
قتلهم ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه هي
العمليات عسكريات همم متواصله في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هناك عمليات اعتقال ايضا هناك
8 فلسطين جرى اعتقالهم هذه الليله ااه هذا
الحال القى بظلاله على الاوضاع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في محافظه جنين تحديدا هناك
اعلنا الاضطراب الشامل هذا اليوم تعطلت
فيه المؤسسات والمدارس وكافه
العامه والخاصه في هذه المدينه حدادا على
ارواح من التقوى برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
فجر هذا اليوم وايضا بالامس
ومن قتل ايضا خلال اليومين الماضيين
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هي تشهد التوترا همم
غير مسبوق هناك همم العديد من الدعوات من
قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه ومن قبل النشطات
بان تكون هذا اليوم وايضا يوم غدا الجمعه
ان يكون هناك تصعيد همم تخرج تظاهرات
احتجاجيه وان يكون هناك همم مواجهات مع
مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال عند نقاط التماس
عندما داخل المدن في المدن في الضفه
الغربيه اذا الامور تتجه الى مزيد من
التصعيد وذلك في ظل هذا همم
الانفلات كما يسمونه وعمليات عدم همم ضبط
النفس همم من قبل ال جي الجيش الاسرائيلي
وعمليات القتل المستمر همم
هذا يؤدي بالتالي كما تقول الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه الى تازم الوضع وربما انفجار
شامل في الاراضي الفلسطينيه نتيجه هذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي مسجد سعيد من مراسلنا
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
التوضيحات